do you remember some of the early
challenges that stick in your mind that
was just like yeah there's so many well
my favorite is the uh trojan horse yeah
oh what was that first of all we had no
budget we had no freaking money back
then
so they wanted this huge trojan horse to
hide all our writers in left outside of
letterman's stage door
right it was a comedy bit
conan was going to send over writers to
letterman we were going to take over the
letter we were supposed to infiltrate
his show he wrote it brian rich wrote it
but you were in charge i shot the whole
thing and we had to shoot it and edit it
the same day well we didn't have a
budget to build that thing so i had two
friends of mine in new jersey build it
in their driveway wait seriously so so
it didn't have a studio a a shop a stamp
on it everything we did the beginning of
our show was illegal
i think there's a statute of limitations
right i think we're safe we broke every
rule you could possibly break union or
building i love this and i'm not kidding
i believe you i we used to never get
permits to shoot any we would just go
out and shoot when we did the trojan
horse we had an 18-wheeled uh dump truck
that once the horse was left there we
ran through it with a dump truck right
and smashed it we backed up we backed up
i was sitting shotgun we backed up to
eighth avenue and we're getting ready to
go and i look ahead of me and adio had
not cleared 53rd street jeff adio was
the production coordinator at the time
yeah and there was a wall of people
right in front of where we were going
just to set the picture the first of all
this trojan horse can you describe how
lar you said friends built it in a
driveway that blows my mind because can
you describe how yuju was it was about
18 feet high and about
16 to 20 feet long oh wow all on wheels
and there was a door inside one of the
legs
where all the riders got in
before the truck hit them yeah it was a
functioning trojan horse was there a
bathroom no
it was a kitchen yeah a kitchenette
the whole idea was we sent it from our
studio which was only three blocks away
from letterman's studio which is now
colbert's studio the old ed sullivan
theater right so we pushed it across 7th
avenue down 53rd to the stage door
entrance of the letterman across 7th
across broadway right and so then
the end of it was
you mentioned this this giant dump truck
was going to barrel down 53rd and smash
it to smithereens oh
correct with the writers inside yeah yes
they were actors so they were expendable
so you're saying jeff adio the
coordinator didn't he didn't clear 53rd
street there was a wall of people from
the from corner corner on 53rd it was
like right in our path yeah because i
wanted to be on tv so what i i went well
i told the truck driver to drive back up
there so we drove back up i said jeff do
you think we might want to get rid of
these people which he did okay so they
just yelled at him like if you don't
move you you may get run over by a truck
exactly i remember martin scorsese was
the guest after that aired
and he just went on and on he really
liked it oh was he impressed with the
directing
yeah he just liked the bit so that was
sweet uh yeah so a lot of stuff was
built illegally back then i didn't know
that [ __ ] yeah remember the caterpillar
remember the catapults no the catapults
they they called for a meeting in the in
the uh conference room on seven or nine
whatever the hell we were on after work
on a friday okay on monday morning they
wanted to have that they wanted to
somehow drop gummy worms over the whole
audience
so i'm sitting down at one end of the
table and jeff ross is up at the other
end our producers and i'm thinking
literally in about three minutes i
calculated how to build a catapult that
would throw gummy worms i went to new
jersey to our stage manager's house
built it that weekend dropped it off in
the city on my way back through to long
island where i lived and then monday
morning we set it up and when we let the
catapult go with the gummy worms on it
yeah they flew about eight feet and
landed on the floor in front of the
house
so i was worried it was going to go the
other way and be so powerful that they
took someone's side that's what i was
waiting for so i'm sitting there and i
said don't worry about it which is just
a couple of adjustments and i went back
and i tightened up the bungee cords to
give it more power
yeah for the live show they went back
uh-oh eight feet in front of the band
again
no don't change no nothing and conan
stands up
he puts both hands on the desk leans
over and he goes let's hear it for the
crappiest catapults on television
[Laughter]
jersey built the next morning they
wanted to do this bluebird of happiness
a bit called the bluebird of happiness
okay yeah and it's it's supposed to fly
in and land on somebody's shoulder i
think mike gordon okay so they're all
going well how are we going to do this
how are we going to do this right from
the other end of the table i go i got
catapults